Louis Pasteur was the chemist who has gone
down in history as one of the fathers of microbiology.
He is famous for several accomplishments that
changed science as we know it, including the
pasteurization process of killing bacteria
from liquids, and paving the way for immunology
by creating life-saving vaccines.
These accomplishments are just the tip of
the iceberg, because without Pasteur’s revolutionary
germ theory, modern medicine would not be
anything like it is today.
On this episode of Biographics, we are talking
about the life and work of Louis Pasteur,
and why he was one of the greatest minds in
history.
Early Life and Education
Louis Pasteur was born in France on December
27, 1822.
He was raised in a town called Arbois by his
parents, Jean-Joseph Pasteur, and Jeanne Etiennette
Roqui.
His father served as a sergeant major during
the Napoleonic Wars, and received the Legion
of Honor.
After the war, Jean-Joseph worked as a full-time
leather tanner, like generations of Pasteur
men before him.
Even though this was the family business,
Jean-Joseph did not want to force his own
son to carry on the tanning trade, and was
open to allowing him to find his own passion.
Usually, when we hear stories of accomplished
academic minds like Louis Pasteur, we imagine
that they may have been a genius all their
lives.
In reality, young Louis was a very average
student in school.
As a young man, he was actually far more interested
in sketching works of art than reading his
textbooks.
He spent a lot of his time drawing and painting,
using the Jura Mountains as his inspiration.
Louis Pasteur’s father encouraged him to
follow his passion for art, and considered
the endeavour to be just as valuable as academic
goals.
Jean-Joseph always encouraged Louis to read
as many books as possible so that he remained
curious about the world around him.
As a veteran, he also instilled a sense of
national pride in Louis, and duty to the people
of France.
Since he spent most of his young life daydreaming
and sketching, Louis actually fell so far
behind academically, that he had to receive
a lot of tutoring at Collège d'Arbois, which
is where he went to secondary school before
he attended university at the École Normale
Supérieure in Paris.
This is where he began taking classes in science.
Chemistry became his new passion, and he had
the goal of earning his PhD.
In 1847, he received his doctorate degree,
and this set the course for the rest of his
life.
A Career in Chemistry
While he was earning his PhD, Louis Pasteur
taught chemistry at a secondary school called
Dijon Lycée before he became a research chemist
at the University of Strasbourg.
When he was just 25 years old, he already
made discoveries that became vital in developing
vaccines in the future.
Microscopes had existed for hundreds of years
before Louis Pasteur was born, but new improvements
on the machine helped scientists to discover
the existence of microorganisms.
Louis Pasteur was far from the only scientist
to be studying microorganisms at the time,
but he was one of the very first.
He is widely considered to be one of the “fathers”
of the field that would later be called “microbiology.”
In 1849, Louis Pasteur was attempting to solve
issues that wine makers were having while
fermenting grapes.
Some batches of wine would go sour very quickly
while others were not, even when the ingredients
and process were exactly the same every time.
Wine makers could not figure out why this
was happening.
Pasteur was able to gather tartaric acid,
which is one of the chemicals present in the
sediment of the wine during the fermentation
process.
After dissolving the tartaric acid, Pasteur
was able to pass polarized light through the
sample in order to observe it.
He discovered that there was a nearly-identical
compound known as “paratartaric acid”
in the wine sediments.
Every other scientist who had observed the
same samples assumed that the chemical was
the same, because it has the same composition
as tartaric acid.
However, while these molecules seem identical
at first, they are actually mirror images
of one another.
You can think of it as being either left or
right-handed versions of the same chemical,
with one of them causing the grapes to go
sour.
Today, this process that Pasteur discovered
of finding the mirror version of a chemical
compound is known as “molecular chirality”,
and it is actually extremely important in
pharmaceutical chemistry, because a left-or-right
handed version may react completely differently
once it is metabolised in the human body,
even though it has the same chemical composition.
His discovery in the variations between the
structure and shape of a molecule also led
to the field of stereochemistry.
With just this one discovery, Louis Pasteur
was able to fix a problem, and also pave the
way for future scientists in several fields
of chemistry.
This alone would have been a huge accomplishment
that would have put his name down in history,
but he was far from finished with his life’s
work.
Personal Life
Louis Pasteur met his future wife, Marie Laurent,
while he was working at the University of
Strasbourg.
Marie was the daughter of the school’s rector,
so she spent most of her life in an academic
environment.
She worked in the school’s laboratory, and
was assigned as Louis Pasteur’s lab assistant
and “amanuensis.”
This is someone who writes down the scientific
information, and assists in making sketches
of his discoveries.
Marie was a very well-educated woman, and
she would have had a lot of scientific background
knowledge in order for her to understand and
record the information.
If she was born in a different time, there
is no doubt that she would have been a full-fledged
chemist as well.
French society at the time found it to be
inappropriate for women to become scientists.
But Marie and Louis respected one another,
and the two of them were truly devoted to
this work.
It only makes sense that they were perfect
for one another both inside and outside of
the laboratory.
Louis Pasteur was 25 years old when he made
the discoveries in wine sediments, and the
two of them were able to share the victory
of a job well done.
This would be only the beginning of their
teamwork.
The two were married on May 29, 1849.
Louis Pasteur was 26, and Marie was 23.
As the years went on, Marie continued to assist
Louis in his experiments.
Without her knowledge and professionalism
by his side, he may not have been able to
accomplish as much as he did in his career.
They went on to have five children together,
but tragically, only two would survive childhood.
As parents who lost three children, they knew
the pain that all parents feel when their
children die from a disease that could have
been prevented, if only there was a vaccine
that existed to help them.
The two of them became determined to devote
their careers to saving the lives of other
children, and they were eventually able to
accomplish
just that.
Germ Theory and Pasteurization
Before he could begin studying diseases, Louis
Pasteur still needed to do the scientific
research that was paying the bills.
In 1854, Pasteur became a chemistry professor
at the University of Lille, and he was paid
to continue researching issues in alcohol
manufacturing.
He became the Dean of the Science department,
as well, and helped to mentor the rest of
the faculty.
In 1861, Pasteur discovered anaerobiosis,
which is crucial in understanding how yeast
and sugar formed alcohol during the fermentation
process.
Even though fermentation had been going on
for thousands of years of human history, no
one else had been able to explain the “how”
and “why” of the chemical process.
So, today, everyone running a hipster microbrewery
has Louis Pasteur to thank for their careers
making craft beer.
Once he fully understood the fermentation
process, Pasteur had a theory that these invisible
organisms called “germs” and “bacteria”
were responsible for causing wine, beer, and
milk to go sour.
He proved that by boiling these liquids, he
could kill the bacteria, and then cool to
it to make it drinkable again.
The first successful test was completed on
April 20th, 1862.
That process of heating and cooling was named
after him; so it is now known as “pasteurization”.
It is still used today.
Louis Pasteur was able to move on from the
food industry, and begin studying disease,
which had been his goal.
In 1865, he was able to prove that microbes
were causing a disease that destroyed silkworm
eggs.
His wife, Marie, assisted him in growing the
silk worms, and keeping them alive during
the course of the experiment.
He was able to develop a prevention for contamination,
and saved the silk-making industry around
the world.
So, aside from our clean wine and beer, we
also need to thank him for our fancy silk
robes and pajamas.
Once he was beginning to understand how bacteria
caused illnesses, he was beginning to come
up with his “germ theory”.
For the majority of human history, people
did not know about the existence of germs,
and they did not fully understand the immune
system.
The widely-held belief was the “Miasma Theory”,
which was that diseases are caused by a poisonous
vapor in the air that only came out at night.
Yes, it sounds truly ridiculous in retrospect,
but people had absolutely no idea how or why
human beings contracted illnesses.
In hospitals, doctors and nurses never even
bothered to wash their hands, because they
truly did not understand the spread of disease.
Human waste would sometimes make its way into
the water system, which would trigger huge
outbreaks of infectious disease, all because
people did not understand that germs existed.
Other scientists had proposed a germ theory
long before Louis Pasteur, but it was often
dismissed.
People had believed in Miasma Theory for so
long, it had become the truth.
In England, a scientist named Dr. John Snow
(Not to be confused with the character from
Game of Thrones) was able to save London from
the cholera outbreak by convincing the town
to shut down a water pump that had been infected
by human waste.
Louis Pasteur would have probably read about
Snow’s breakthrough in bacterial research,
and it would inspire him to push the germ
theory as well.
Soon enough, Pasteur and the other fathers
of microbiology were able to prove that the
Miasma Theory was nothing but a fantasy, and
the acknowledgement that germs existed would
change the medical industry was we know it.
The Accidental Invention of Vaccines
In 1868, Louis Pasteur was just 46 years old
when he suffered a severe stroke, and he became
partially paralyzed.
Instead of going to a hospital, Pasteur was
treated in his home.
Sixteen leeches were placed behind his ears
to clear the blood that had pooled around
his cerebral hemorrhage.
After the doctor left with the leeches, Louis
Pasteur was left in his wife Marie.
He was very lucky that she had such an extensive
science background, because she helped to
rehabilitate him to overcome his paralysis.
This story is usually glossed over in many
of the history books.
We tend to glorify the major accomplishments
of successful people, and ignore the struggles.
Louis Pasteur was still very human, and recovering
from a stroke is never an easy task.
Back in the 1800’s, a stroke would likely
mean death, or permanent paralysis for the
rest of his life.
Marie nursed him back to health, and encouraged
him to heal so that they could both return
to the laboratory in order to continue their
life’s work of curing diseases.
Even though his health recovered, it would
be years before Louis Pasteur was able to
make another major scientific discovery.
Eight years later, in 1876, Louis Pasteur
made his first major breakthrough since having
his stroke.
At the time, scientists believed in the idea
of “spontaneous generation”.
This was the ridiculous notion that living
creatures could spontaneously generate from
inanimate substances.
People believed that living creatures were
“born” asexually, like mice forming in
rotting food, food and frogs emerging from
the mud.
This belief was so common, there were even
some scientific papers claiming to come up
with a “recipe” for growing your own mice.
Pasteur publicly denounced this age-old belief
of spontaneous generation, but there were
still plenty of people who had their doubts.
In the past, other scientists like Francesco
Redi had attempted to prove that spontaneous
generation was not real.
He sealed a piece of meat in a jar with a
lid, proving that as long as flies did not
land on food, larva did not appear.
However, people did not believe this, because
they thought oxygen may be necessary for the
so-called “recipe”.
The only way Pasteur was able to convince
the public that animals are not born out of
food was to design custom swan-necked bottles
that curved in such a way that allowed oxygen
to get through, but it would be impossible
for flies to crawl inside.
He boiled beef broth, and left it inside this
swan neck bottle.
Finally, the idea of spontaneous generation
was debunked.
Two years later, in 1878, Pasteur was studying
diseases when he accidently exposed chickens
to an attenuated culture of chicken cholera.
However, the chickens did not die from the
disease.
In fact, it had the exact opposite.
When they were later exposed to the full-fledged
chicken cholera virus, they had become immune.
This was his very first vaccine.
At the time, the idea that he could replicate
these results in human beings was still years
away from actually happening.
But he theorized that if he could replicate
that same process, he just may be able to
create vaccines for some of the deadliest
diseases of the time, like anthrax, tuberculosis,
smallpox, and anthrax.
A year later, in 1881, Louis Pasteur developed
a vaccine for Anthrax, and cured several sheep
in his laboratory from the disease.
Even after conducting the same experiment
hundreds of times, the scientific community
still did not believe Louis Pasteur’s results.
Even when everyone mocked and ridiculed him,
he did not back down, because he knew that
he was right.
For years, people refused to believe him,
until he traveled to the town of Pouilly le
Fort, which had a farm filled with sheep that
had been infected with Anthrax.
Pasteur injected his vaccine into all of the
sick sheep in front of a large crowd of people.
Sure enough, all of the sheep recovered, and
the newspapers finally declared that he truly
had invented the cure.
He once wrote this advice to future generations
on how to deal with haters; “Do not let
yourself be tainted with a barren skepticism.”
After Louis Pasteur’s germ theory was published
in academic papers, and there was a significant
amount of proof that his animal vaccines were
working.
Educated people with open minds understood
the concept of bacteria, and they began to
make efforts to improve public health and
safety in France.
Following Louis Pasteur’s discoveries about
germs, a politician named Eugene Poubelle
began enforcing the first garbage cans in
Paris in 1884.
At first, citizens were outraged that they
could no longer throw their trash wherever
they wanted.
Despite dealing with all of the skepticism
and push-back from the public, Poubelle continued
to mandate that garbage cans were necessary
in every home.
Today, we take garbage cans for granted, but
this was a huge step in disease prevention.
Over the next few years, the spread of disease
began to fall dramatically in France, and
other countries around the world began to
copy the idea.
However, just like every other scientific
discovery in human history, there were people
who still refused to believe in the germ theory,
despite all of the proof that was out there.
Pasteur had plenty of critics who still tried
to claim that he was incorrect.
Louis Pasteur had a bitter rivalry with another
scientist named Antoine Béchamp, who completely
dismissed his germ theory.
Instead of believing in the existence of germs,
Béchamp published his own theory of “pleomorphism”.
But, of course, the truth always has a way
of coming out, and Pasteur continued to be
the one who came out on top.
The Rabies Vaccine
Louis Pasteur continued to prove to the world
that his germ theory was correct, and that
infections were the cause of disease.
At the time, rabies and anthrax were both
very serious problems in animals.
If a dog was infected and bit someone, it
was guaranteed that they would die an excruciatingly
painful death.
After years of overcoming so much doubt in
the scientific community, Louis Pasteur was
now well regarded for his achievements in
science and medicine.
In 1873, The Académie de Médecine elected
to bring him on as an associate member of
their society.
And in 1882, he was accepted into the Académie
Française.
While he was doing his research there, he
decided to devote his research to curing rabies.
In 1883, Pasteur was creating the rabies vaccine
by acquiring rabbits that had been infected
by the virus, and attempting to inject the
vaccine into dogs.
After trial and error, he was able to cure
dogs who had been infected, and bring them
back to health.
But using the vaccine on a human being had
not been done until 1885.
On July 6th, a 9-year old boy named Joseph
Meister was brought to Louis Pasteur in Paris.
His parents had traveled for two days from
Alsace after he was bitten by a rabid dog.
At first, Pasteur hesitated, because he had
only ever experimented with the vaccine on
dogs.
But the boy was going to die anyway, so Pasteur
agreed to try.
He took an emulsion from the spinal cord of
a rabbit who had rabies, and formed a vaccine.
The process did not happen overnight.
Over the next 10 days, Joseph was given 13
more injections of the vaccine, and he was
hospitalized for three months.
After the boy made a full recovery, Louis
Pasteur became famous around the world for
finding the cure.
On the 20th of October that same year, an
adult male who had been infected with rabies
six days earlier was brought to Louis Pasteur.
He repeated the same vaccination process as
before, and the man made a full recovery.
Now, there was no doubt that the vaccine truly
worked.
In 1886, Louis Pasteur began to treat over
350 patients who had been infected with rabies
in Europe and the United States.
Louis Pasteur’s wife, Marie, traveled the
world with him, and nursed the sick children
with rabies for months at a time while her
husband was preparing the vaccines and giving
the injections.
Of course, today, this same vaccine is what
helps keep our dogs and cats safe from rabies.
No matter where he went, whether he could
speak the language or not, the story was always
the same.
He was very proud that he was able to accomplish
this on behalf of France.
He said, “Science knows no country, because
knowledge belongs to humanity, and is the
torch which illuminates the world.
Science is the highest personification of
the nation, because that nation will remain
the first which carries the furthest the works
of thought and intelligence.”
During this process of meeting and healing
over 350 people, Pasteur got to know many
of his patients.
Many of them were young children who were
bitten when playing with their dogs.
He said, “When I approach a child, he inspires
in me two sentiments; tenderness for what
he is, and respect for what he may become.”
Louis Pasteur wanted to save the lives of
these sick children so that they could have
a chance to grow up, and he wanted his vaccines
to do the same for future generations all
over the world.
Finally, he was recognized as a scientist
worthy of his own research facility, and a
fundraising campaign began to create the Pasteur
Institute in Paris.
This was finally inaugurated on November 14,
1888.
When he turned 70 years old, he was given
a spectacular birthday party at The University
of Paris, and some of the most prestigious
doctors and scientists were there to celebrate
his life and works.
Louis Pasteur he died in 1895, at the age
of 73.
His body is now in a crypt in the Pasteur
Institute.
But his work has lived on far after his passing.
Today, we still use pasteurization in the
food industry, and his breakthroughs in medicine
were just the beginning.
Other scientists began to use the same methods
to create vaccines for diseases that had once
killed thousands of people.
There is no telling just how many millions
of people would have died without the work
he was able
to accomplish.